[Music]
thanks very much I just wanted to
recommend a documentary to everyone and
then and then I'm gonna go it's about
the it's about the men and one woman who
abbreviated all 50 states down to two
letters all you all you have to know for
this is that we have 50 states in
America and they each have a two capital
letter abbreviation but that wasn't
always the case
up until I want to say 1973 and so I
will up until 1973 every state had its
own length of abbreviation and it was
chaos like Massachusetts was mas s
period Florida was Fla Utah was Utah
they just dropped the age not much of an
abbreviation but then the post office
said no every state has to have a to
capital letter abbreviation and so they
convened a crack squad of abbreviate
errs they assembled a ragtag outfit of
rogues misfits and ne'er-do-wells
how often do well they're in there and
they're did well and they were charged
with abbreviating all 50 states down to
two letters now I read this description
to the documentary and much like you
thought to myself how are they gonna
make a 90 minute documentary about a
task that couldn't have taken more than
six minutes to complete what boy was I
wrong it was an adventure ups and downs
ins and outs friends became enemies
enemies became friends they started off
they thought it was gonna be easy
because Alabama loaded them into a false
sense of security they said Alabama al
holy crap this is easy work we're gonna
finish before they stop serving
breakfast in the hotel restaurant and
the boss said guys if we finish before
they stop serving breakfast breakfast is
on me and then one guy said oh I hope
they have an omelet station just just
for context the omelet station had just
been invented and it was and it it was
sweeping the nation
and this other guy said you know what
I'm not I'm not comfortable with the
omelet station because I I feel like the
omelet chef resents you like he didn't
want to be the omelet chef nobody dreams
of being omelet chef he wanted to be the
chef chef and now instead of now instead
of giving the orders he's taking the
orders from your stupid wife and your
ugly kids I think one day is gonna snap
and I don't want to be there when it
happens
and they were like well why don't you
just get eggs benedict he said I don't
like holiday sauce they said did you
just say holiday sauce
yeah why cuz it's hollandaise you
and then the boss said guys I hate to be
a nudge but could we get back to
abbreviate in the States we still have
49 left an apologies remained an
understanding was reached and they got
back to abbreviate and they said what
snacks they said Alaska everybody cool
with al
but somebody caught it when man
sheepishly raised his hand since all
right I think we might have used that
one before
are you sure I'm pretty sure well let's
check the minute Dottie Dottie read the
minutes back to us hon
Don Dottie was the wife tracking
secretary every 1970s office had a
wisecracking secretary this one his name
was Dottie Dottie Dottie was a pistol
you would love you she was a real hot
ticket Dottie listen to one thought he
said they said Dottie read the minutes
how Dottie is this so read the minutes
back though this is so Dottie and she
goes you mean the minute
[Applause]
sorry sorry what are we gonna do with
you spank my ass and make me a martini
daughter you're incorrigible now leave
the minutes back to us you Randy minx
and she said it's hollandaise you
- dotty
how do you know Shakespeare you don't
know hollandaise that's a paradox Alaska
al Alabama al we did use that one before
boss and the Boston guys not a big deal
we'll come back to it it's not gonna
happen again
certainly not gonna happen 27 more times
foreshadowing some what's next Arizona a
I there we go we're back on track next
Arkansas no we'll come back - it's not
gonna happen again what's next
California CA there we go next Colorado
CEO momentum Connecticut we are screwed
somebody needs a drink
not now Dottie
not now you vulgar lush by the time they
got to Maine Maryland Massachusetts
followed by Michigan Minnesota
Mississippi and Missouri shots were
fired they were at each other's throats
they did what any savvy business would
do they hired a consultant they brought
in a contractor I'm sorry not a
contractor a contractor and then a man
who made words smaller by combining them
or apostrophizing them and this guy was
this guy was the best he was a legend
within that world like you wouldn't know
his name but you know his work like he
wrote such timeless classics as o´clock
many years ago people would say it's
nine of the clock it's ten of the clock
this visionary said we don't need the I
can do that with a sky ,
[Laughter]
[Applause]
yeah he also wrote would've could've
should've the Holy Trinity of regret he
wrote he wrote the penny very innovative
we dove he looked at we would have and
said I can do that in half the letters
it was not without controversy it also
wrote the most controversial contraction
of all time he wrote won't people said
how are you gonna brief he it will not
not use a single out and he said watch
me are you saying I won't be able to do
it I just did
[Applause]
you